hat die raumsonde cassini spuren von
leben auf dem saturnmond enceladus
entdeckt am donnerstag wird die nasa
eine pressekonferenz zum thema ozean
welten in unserem sonnensystem abhalten
und das macht sie für gewöhnlich nur
wenn es spektakuläre entdeckungen zu
vermelden gibt uns schon die
teilnehmerliste lässt rückschlüsse auf
diese entdeckung zu werden nämlich alle
puzzle steinchen zusammensetzt dann wird
es wahrscheinlich ziemlich spektakulär
was am donnerstag um 20 uhr verkündet
wird hier könnte es schon mal erfahren
zumindest ziemlich genau bei klicks
umsatzentwicklung herzlich willkommen
obwohl eigentlich werfen wir einen blick
in die vergangenheit die saturnsonde
cassini hat nämlich bereits am 28
oktober 2015 ein absolut spektakuläres
manöver vollführt sie hat ein kunststück
vollbracht für das sie eigentlich gar
nicht vorgesehen war 2005 entdeckte die
sonde aktive geysire auf dem saturnmond
enceladus danach wurde die komplette
mission verändert die instrumente an
bord wurden umprogrammiert und cassini
flug sieben mal durch diese fontänen am
südpol von enceladus und am 28 oktober
durch luchse diese basiere in einer höhe
von knapp 50 kilometern
der absolute höhepunkt das ganze dauert
nur ein paar sekunden und es gibt nur
dieses bild vom überflug aber ansonsten
wurde nichts aber auch rein gar nichts
über diesen überflug vermeldet seit mehr
als einem jahr herrscht funkstille
niemand hat sich bis heute dazu geäußert
es wirkt fast so als ob eine
nachrichtensperre verhängt wurde auch
dieses bild wurde lediglich abgefangen
aber nicht offiziell veröffentlicht
aber es kommt noch besser wenn man sich
nämlich die teilnehmer der
pressekonferenz ansieht dann kann man
schon erahnen worum es geht da ist zum
beispiel linda spilker wissenschaftlerin
beim cassini projekt oder handarbeit und
chris kleinen beiden zuständig für das
mittelmass spectrometer an bord von
cassini dafür die untersuchung von
molekülen und ionen zuständig ist und
wenn man sich die ergebnisse des ersten
etwas höheren durchfluss ansieht dann
sind die hinweise mehr als deutlich dass
ein end mittelmass spektrometer ams fand
einfache und komplexe organische
verbindung das bedeutet erstmal nicht
solche verbindungen können nämlich auch
ohne leben in der nähe von heißen
quellen zum beispiel durch chemische
reaktionen entstehen aber wenn dann noch
mary yoytek astrobiologin teilnehmerin
der konferenz ist ihr job sind
schlichtweg außerirdische irgendetwas
scheint die nasa darin zu bestärken das
thema außerirdisches leben auf dieser
pressekonferenz zu thematisieren
vor dem vorbeiflug hat die nasa sehr
klar angesagt was untersucht werden soll
so sollte die sonde mit dem ams
molekularen wasserstoff nachweisen
er wäre ein
hinweis auf hydrothermale vorgänger auf
enceladus daraus könne geschlossen
werden wie groß der bereich wäre in dem
leben auf dem mond existieren könnte die
forscher sind nämlich davon überzeugt
dass unter einer 30 bis 40 km dicken
eisschicht und da am südberg können sie
etwas dünner sein
in etwa zehn kilometer tiefe
salzhaltiger ozean ist salz wurden
nämlich auch bereits in den fontänen der
geysire gefunden während dort unten
hitze quellen könnte in ihrem umfeld
leben existieren salzwasser und hitze
werden genau das rezept für leben die
zusammensetzung wäre dann genau die wie
hier auf der erde und eben genau die aus
der das leben hier auf der erde
entstanden ist und der cd a der staub
detektor an bord der sollte ich die
schweren partikel in den geysiren
untersuchen weil hier komplexere
organische strukturen vermutet werden
und das scheint vielleicht der
springende punkt zu sein hat der cdu den
entscheidenden hinweis gefunden
zwar kann cassini nicht wirklich leben
nachweisen aber die wissenschaftler
wollten im nachgang szenarien im labor
entwerfen die zur zusammensetzung der
gefundenen organischen verbindungen
führen
das denkbare szenario für die
pressekonferenz wäre jetzt dass dort
eben verbindung gefunden worden die nur
zu einer situation passen leben
das wäre wirklich der absolute hammer
und würde unser weltbild komplett
verändern und das würde auch die lange
wartezeit vom durchflug bis zur
veröffentlichung der ergebnisse erklären
wären auf enceladus hinweise auf leben
gefunden worden wäre das ein ganz klares
indiz dafür dass überall leben entsteht
wo bestimmte bedingungen herrschen und
die betonung liege hier auf über all das
universum wäre voller leben ich bin
ebenfalls absolut mega gespannt den link
zur live übertragung der pressekonferenz
den findet ihr in der video beschreibung
ich bin auf jeden fall dabei ich bin
zwar im zug aber ich gucke was ich
mitbekommen kann und macht im anschluss
natürlich ein video und wenn ihr das und
alle weiteren täglichen videos nicht
verpassen wollen dann drückt mir hier
ein abo aufs auge und gebt mir ein auf
die glocke bis dann bleibt dran und wer
bisher noch nicht dran geblieben ist das
habt ihr verpasst die besten videos von
pixum science fiction bei